would you like to get your refund or
what do you want to do less than a month
until the big journey and abu sayed says
he faces a refund bill of nearly 280 000
pounds
and this was meant to be the year of
post-pandemic recovery all of the uk's
roughly 500 hajj travel operators face
similar issues after saudi arabia
announced this week that visas and
travel packages can only be issued
through an online lottery system called
matawiff it goes through the online
portal packages it's not i've heard that
it's not protected they want to go to
hajj traditionally the way their
predecessor they went to hajj they want
to go with
their tour guides a hajj god like myself
any mom like myself what does it mean
for your business
if the saudi authority if they don't
come back to hide agencies
then i would say there is no future for
height agencies at all
the change means anyone from the uk
wishing to perform hajj this year needs
to book through this online portal
it also means anyone already booked via
their travel agent has to cancel those
plans and start again
the saudis say this portal is
revolutionary in that it offers bookings
direct to consumers helping to tackle
fraud and making hajj more accessible
but british parliamentarians are worried
the saudi package won't meet uk travel
regulations
if something goes wrong what is the
ultimate comeback for the pilgrimage
because under the old system you had
eight or protected packages so if we
went wrong you had a system of
compensation matawif has told sky news
details of the packages on offer this
year including prices will be sent to
selected applicants today british
muslims now need to put their faith in
the saudi system if they want to get
here sadia chowdhury sky news